[Musica]
sono davvero molto felice di essere con
voi
grazie
chi inventò geniale questo della
plastica
[Musica]
quante cose meravigliose si possono fare
o
ma non ci hanno insegnato o salve non
abbiamo imparato a gestirlo
[Musica]
sin dal primo momento che si inventata
la plastica prima ancora che si stesse
la prima bottiglia il primo ingegnere il
primo momento già poteva sapere che cosa
sarebbe successo la scienza la tecnica
l'economia
tutti hanno progredito ma non ci hanno
creato la cultura dell'utilizzo non ci
hanno insegnato salva progredire
problemi e non è crescere in tecnologia
su aggiungere di più e di più tecnologia
progresso è il vero progresso e che
l'uomo in quanto uomo possa progredire
non c'è ecologia senza un'adeguata
antropologia antropologia suona a un
termine teorico qualcosa un po fuori
della realtà ma in realtà non è così
antropologia e il pensiero sull'uomo
tutto a un'antropologia tutto ha una
concezione dell'uomo da dove veniamo
dove andiamo
ma soprattutto il senso della vita
pensiamo per esempio l'architettura se
per me
l'uomo è un essere che serve per
produrre per me allora noi basta fare un
edificio con una stanza un bagno in
maniera che lui vada mangi riposi e poi
torni a lavorare per me ma se invece per
me l'uomo è un essere destinato a essere
felice con la sua famiglia con i suoi
fidi con i suoi amici con la sua vita
dove il lavoro è quella realtà che le
permette dare da mangiare la sua
famiglia
la realtà con la quale lui diventa più
mano la realtà con la quale lui crea la
cultura allora la cassa un'altra cosa
la casa deve più stanze perché la vita
si realizza con diverse persone
in diverse circle cir con fans della
vita ma pure vorno che quando l'uomo con
il marito litiga con la moglie possano
avere due stanze perché così prendono un
pochettino del tempo e poi tornano a
dialogare tutto tutto a un'antropologia
un pensiero sull'uomo tutto quello che
facciamo tutto quello che abbiamo tutte
le leggi i regolamenti tutto tutta una
antropologia più esplicita o implicita
da dove viene e che intende realizzare
come sappiamo se un'antropologia è buona
o meno antropologia bona e quella che
pensa all uomo a tutto l'uomo non ha una
parte a tutti gli uomini e non soltanto
ad alcuni non ci sono due crisi separate
un ambientale e un'altra sociale bensì
una sola e complessa crisi socio
ambientale
siamo abituati a pensare alla realtà
come compartimenti stagni un problema
una soluzione
un tempo uno spazio un altro problema
un'altra soluzione così via ma in realtà
non è così e tutti lo sappiamo se una
sofferenza colpisce la nostra vita
non possiamo pensare agire come automi e
che quindi possiamo andare così
automaticamente nella vita
no ne ha neanche se arriva un momento
bello quando arriva l'amore quanto
colori che c'è neanche possiamo
immaginare la vita come una realtà tutta
mescolata ai problemi alla famiglia e
lavoro lavora famiglia crowe le leve
tutto non si sostiene ma in mezzo a
tutte e due realtà ce n'è una via di
mezzo concepire la vita così come un
sistema dove tutto è collegato una
realtà unica
che va gestita perché dobbiamo
accompagnare la persona e per ciò che
non esistono due crisi una umana è un
ecologica ma bensì una e complessa
realtà socio ecologica questa realtà va
gestita in quanto tali e per ciò che se
la realtà che abbiamo fatto da noi non
sta bene non potremo mai risolverla se
noi non cambiamo per primo perché anche
se riempiamo del rovo tini che puliscano
l'ambiente altre cose se non cambiamo
noi faremo perfino funzionare male i
robottini cicerone diceva non novice
solo una di sumus non siamo nati
soltanto per noi
l'altro giorno venivo circolava una
strada roma molto ampia
a destra parcheggiate a propria fila
sinistra parcheggiate avevo profila
quindi strada piccolina davanti a una
macchina dietro di me tante macchine in
un momento quello davanti vedo un
giornalaio e fermali li ferma scende a
comprare il giornale
allora io timidamente faccio un
colpettino dei clacson tanto della serie
ti puoi spostare un pochettino così noi
possiamo trascorrere la strada
allora lui bello nervoso si gira e mi
dice sei in fretta non puoi aspettare un
attimo devo comprare il giornale
cioè noi eravamo torti tutta la figlia
che volevamo semplicemente circolare
questo è il problema
ognuno di noi pensa che siamo il centro
dell'umanità che abbiamo la ragione di
tutto egoisti
centri ci pensiamo che la verità ilbono
il giusto lo definiamo noi
guardate che il problema avere la crisi
nucleare e questo alcuni che si sentono
onnipotenti che pensano che il loro
pensiero al pensiero giusto e quindi si
sentono con il diritto del premere un
bottone e sterminare la vita del milione
di persone
la vita le vittime innocenti alla nostra
vita questo nel macro ma pure nel micro
nella nostra realtà
se noi quando facciamo le cose anche se
pensiamo che stanno male comunque le
facciamo
guardate che noi non siamo diversi noi
non ci situiamo all'inizio di una nuova
storia
tutti possono essere grandi perché tutti
possono servire ti serve solo un cuore
pieno di grazia un'anima generata dall
amore diceva amate martin luther king
se provassimo a rovesciare invece questa
realtà dell'egoismo e l'egocentrismo e
invece di usare l'uomo provassimo a
servirlo invece di ignorarlo provassimo
a scoprirlo quanta felicità ci sarebbe
nel mondo
quanta felicità ci sarebbe della nostra
vita se ci fosse meno emoticon e più
carezze e abbracci davvero se ci fosse
meno giochi online in meno computer e ci
fosse più tempo condiviso
quanta felicità nelle nostre famiglie i
nostri amici in noi stessi servire e
servire
che bellezza poter servire e servire
veramente cambia la vita di tutti cambia
la vita è colui che fa il servizio di
colui che riceva il servizio colui che
riceva il servizio perché un pezzo della
sua vita della sua sofferenza e la sua
mancanza
sparisce semplicemente per qualcuno s'è
deciso da mare aprire gli occhi e dare
un po di se cambia la vita è colui che
serve che offre il servizio perché
perché bellissimo fa felice un altro è
bellissimo poter creare la sorpresa con
le nostre mani e bellissimo sollevare la
sofferenza di qualcuno ma anche a
livello fisiologico fa pure bene servire
pensiamo la meraviglia che si scatena la
nostra fisiologia nel sistema
neuroendocrino endorfina dopamina e
serotonina ossitocina ma soprattutto
sapete che servire servire segno di un
amore che fecondo ma ama gandhi diceva
se potessimo cambiare noi stessi
cambieremo anche le tendenze del mondo
allora per cambiare ed egoisti a
servitori
quali sono le chiavi di raitre una
scoprire noi stessi l'altra scoprire
scoprire l'altro è tersa scoprire in
realtà scoprire noi stessi smettiamo di
guardare alla finestra per vedere gli
altri
e pensare che gli altri non hanno
problemi se la passano bene sono felici
stanno super e noi no
tutti abbiamo problemi tutti abbiamo la
nostra croce tutti abbiamo sofferenza di
portare avanti ma soprattutto tutti
abbiamo
dei toni delle cose meravigliose che
abbiamo noi dobbiamo semplicemente avere
il coraggio di scoprirla del potere
idonei che abbiamo perché quando le
scopriamo possiamo farle fiorire e darle
agli altri essere tutti felice secondo
scoprire gli altri se non troppo
abituati che l'altro stalin e che deve
stare lì perché noi no mio marito è la
mia moglie e mio figlio il mio capo il
mio impiegato sta lì e deve stare lì e
quindi non facciamo niente per
riconquistarli non abbiamo il coraggio e
scoprire i toni e le bellezze che
veramente l'altro sa se apre avessimo il
coraggio di poter scoprire l'altro era
creare le relazioni che avesse con il
tempo si possono consumare un po ma noi
siamo più intelligenti che il calendario
del tempo se ci rendessimo conto è il
terzo punto della natura quando parliamo
de cosmo venature all'ecologia sono cose
troppo grandi per noi e quindi pensiamo
che è una cosa degli altri e non è così
ciascuno nella propria realtà ha una
competenza fare un rubinetto a chiudere
una bottiglia di non buttare ci
rendessimo conto e tutti questi doni
queste meraviglie che abbiamo non
prenderemo più dei rischi dei rischi
della nostra vita
guidando come matti nella strada del
rischi degli affetti giocando con il
telefonino dei rischi della natura
mutando la bottiglia per terra diamo un
passo noi cambieremo la tendenza del
mondo
bergamo 20
sempla tra un le paure muovono gli
esempi trascinano non c'è nessuna
differenza fra il governante che non
vede e provvede nella gestione delle
risorse di un paese e noi che quando si
lavano i denti al mattino non chiudiamo
il rubinetto è una questione
semplicemente d'opportunità delle
dimensioni delle opportunità
l'atteggiamento e lo stesso quindi la
strada sta in cambiare noi però non
basta è necessario tramandare dare ai
più piccoli ai giovani questo che
abbiamo nel cuore
se siamo un web perché abbiamo qualcosa
diamolo perché uno più uno che ha un
tessuto e questo se tutte sotto si
chiama cultura guardate quanti siamo qua
350 se ognuno di noi prendessero come
principio fare qualcosa nella propria
realtà e tram andassimo a coloro che
stanno tanto a noi quanto quanto bene
potremo fare alla creazione alla nostra
vita
vi racconto un piccolo esempio un
piccolo segreto più che sempre quando
preparavo questo questo intervento mi
sono interrogato pure io gli ho detto se
parlo di questo che cosa posso fare io
nel nostro dicastero alla comunicazione
abbiamo parlato con il prefetto e
proprio per questo evento è però non
fare queste parole abbiamo stavamo
creando un progetto per essere alla fine
del 2 a me 2020 pure noi
l'atrix
molte cose devono riorientare la propria
rotta ma la prima di tutto e l'umanità
che ha bisogno di cambiare non
aspettiamo la tecnologia perfetta la
legge rivoluzionaria il miracolo che
possa venire a cambiare l'umanità e la
natura kennedy nel discorso inaugurale
dell'insediamento diceva agli americani
non chiedeteci cittadini non chiedete al
paese cosa può fare per voi chiedete di
voi cosa potete fare per il vostro paese
l'umanità ha bisogno di cambiare
l'umanità cominciano a me io io in
questa nuova umanità
[Musica]
io sono l'origine grazie
[Applauso]